So if you've seen any of the other
interviews that I've done
here at Udacity, you'll notice
that I'm now in the other chair.
And the reason is that what we're
talking about today is a subject near
and dear to my heart.
It's my dissertation topic,
which is intelligent tutoring systems.
So, Jason has graciously offered
to interview me on this one.
So.
>> So, all right, David.
Let's get started.
So what got you interested in working
in intelligent tutoring systems?
>> So from the time I was
16 until throughout my PhD,
I actually worked as a private tutor.
So I tutored mostly
high school subjects.
Math, physics, things like that.
And it was late in my Master's degree
when I became acquainted with a field
called intelligent tutoring systems.
And it was basically, let's build
AI agents that can do the tutoring.
And the opportunities offered by
them were absolutely enormous for
accessibility, availability,
cutting costs and
being able to distribute these things
to a large number of students.
And so I really wanted to jump on board,
plus I always joke that
if anyone was going to replace me with
an AI agent, it may as well be me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
my initial interest was really wanting
to bring the benefits of tutoring,
one on one tutoring where you have
real individualized feedback and
individualized attention to a much
broader audience of students that
wouldn't be able to
access it other wise.
>> Okay.
All right.
What is the most exciting possibility
of intelligent tutoring systems?
>> So, we've already seen intelligent
tutoring systems do some really exciting
things, things like
Carnegie Learning's Cognitive Tutor for
algebra in high school and
things like that.
But what I think is the most
exciting opportunity is
what the Internet can do to
actually scale these things up.
So right now, we have students
using them in classrooms and
they use them as complements
to their lessons, but
some new initiatives are looking at
actually putting that online, which is
really powerful because it takes that
and it makes it available to everyone.
So things like IXL that do some
rudimentary kind of intelligent tutoring
system principles for the masses.
But what's really, really exciting, and
this is a little bit further out though,
is the idea that, in the future, we
might not just have intelligent tutoring
systems that can kind of
monitor what you do, and
give you feedback that it
already kind of knows about.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But intelligent tutoring systems
that, themselves, can learn.
So if I have a intelligent tutoring
system equipped with some machine
learning that can look
at 100,000 students, and
look at what feedback it
gave to what mistakes and
what actually led to future improvement,
it can actually then improve itself.
It can learn what teaching strategies,
or what feedback,
or what responses are most useful to
students for certain kinds of errors.
>> And then it might be able to start to
unlock some principles of feedback or
some principles of teaching that
we don't even know about yet.
When I was tutoring back
in my earlier life,
I worked with maybe ten
students at a time.
I've probably worked with 50 or 60
students over the course of my career.
And I drew from that a lot.
But 50 or 60 students,
it's a decent knowledge base.
But if we had an AI agent that could
do it based on a 100,000 students or
a million students,
and experiences across
the entire course of their curriculum,
that would be incredibly powerful.
>> Absolutely.
>> And
the other thing is that when I'm
working with students, usually I'd get
them maybe in ninth or tenth grade, and
very often what I would find is that
the difficulties they were having with
a certain concept in math in tenth grade
really went back to difficulties they
had with fractions in fifth grade.
>> Okay.
>> And
really, the ideal would be,
a system like this would prevent
those difficulties from
arising in the first place.
It would teach them well in fifth grade.
But even if it didn't do that, if we
had a intelligent tutoring system that
worked with them throughout their
entire education, it would be able to
look back and say what did I
teach you back in fifth grade?
What difficulties did you have there?
And kind of leverage those right now.
I know that this student has always had
a little bit of trouble with fractions.
So when I come to a new lesson I know
that I can anticipate giving a little
bit more feedback on that.
And couching it in terms of what
I've told them in the past.
So, that kind of long term memory, that
kind of massive data bank really opens
up some really exciting possibilities if
we can figure out a way to harness it.
>> Oh, wow.
Absolutely.
>> What are some of the biggest
challenges facing intelligent
tutoring systems?
>> So, I think there's really two big
challenges that are presently facing
intelligent tutoring systems.
One is the idea of
invisible information.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So when I'm working with a student
and they're working on a particular
problem, I can see the steps they're
writing out, that that is their first
step, that is their second step.
But when they make an error,
I don't necessarily know what
was going on inside their mind.
I can kind of use what they said and
use what they wrote to try and
extrapolate it, but
I don't have a real notion of that.
That comes up in things like algebra,
but it's even more important in things
like science or
some of the more high level classes.
Ideally, we like to build intelligent
tutoring systems that deal with those
levels as well.
When the nature of the problems
themselves becomes much less formal and
much less structured.
And in an algebra problem,
I know that there's,
you know, five steps to get to
the answer to this problem.
But if my problem is,
design a good user interface for
facilitating learning sign language,
I don't know what the problems are.
I don't know what the steps are.
I don't know how to evaluate that.
And so, for those big, open-ended
projects or those big things that aren't
really constrained environments, that's
where we have a lot of information
that's invisible, because it's
inside the student's own head.
And that makes it very difficult for
humans to operate on,
let alone computers.
If they can't see it,
they can't operate on it.
>> Right.
>> And then the other issue is that
there's information that we as
humans can process that right now,
it's difficult for agents to process.
>> For sure.
>> So when I'm working with a student,
I can tell based on their facial
expression, are they bored,
are they tired, are they really excited,
are they really confused,
are they really frustrated.
And those all inform
how I react to them.
If they're frustrated,
I'm going to be a little more patient.
If they're excited, I'm going to
maybe push a little bit further or
connect to some bigger topics.
Right now, computers are starting to
have a little bit of ability to do that
kind of facial recognition, but
it's not quite there yet and
it's not fast enough
to equip a tutor with.
And so the other challenge that those
systems are really going to face is
processing the full range of information
that we humans can process or
reading the student, understanding that,
understanding a little bit about their
background and
the context in which they're working.
So I think those are the two main
challenges that they'll need to
overcome.
>> Okay.
>> So, thank you again, Jason for
peppering me with
questions on my own topic.
>> Absolutely David,
anything for you, you know that.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And thank you all.